[Música]
bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo de
áfrica siete días aquí en france 24 este
es un magazine informativo 100% dedicado
al continente africano mi nombre es
liliana valencia de aquí damos una
mirada en profundidad los hechos de
actualidad de la semana en la cuna de la
humanidad continúa el conflicto ente y
el gobierno de etiopía anunció que la
operación para recuperarme que le ya
está completa el primer ministro había
med aseguró que sus tropas tomaron el
control tras tres semanas de guerra
étnica con rebeldes del cuerno de áfrica
ellos por su parte aseguran que continúa
en pie de lucha y preocupa la crisis
humanitaria según la onu son al menos
110 los aldeanos fallecidos en borno
nigeria persona ataque de presuntos
militantes islamistas afueras de
seguridad buscan a decenas de
desaparecidos las autoridades señalan a
boko haram por la matanza e iniciaron
las honras fúnebres de las víctimas
el actual presidente de burkina faso
rock matriz sean kaboré fue reelecto
para un segundo mandato para los
comicios del pasado 22 de noviembre
kaboré obtuvo más del 57 por ciento de
los votos y su principal reto será poner
freno a la violencia en esta región
iniciamos entonces con la información
aquí en áfrica siete días y empezamos
hablando de etiopía porque a pesar de
que el gobierno asegura haber retomado
mekelle en frente de liberación nacional
de ti y considerado rebelde por el
gobierno nacional afirmó que derribó un
avión militar captura al piloto y retomó
el control de una ciudad de la región al
tiempo que señaló que seguirá luchando
veamos el informe
las versiones encontradas reinan en el
conflicto en la región etíope del tigre
el frente de liberación nacional de el
tigre de considerado rebelde aseguró que
derribó un avión militar capturó al
piloto y retomó la ciudad de acción
cerca de la frontera con eritrea y
google estuvo en sus casas declaraciones
se producen sólo un día después de que
el primer ministro había ahmed anunciará
el control total de meckel en la capital
regional y el fin de la operación
militar que inició el pasado 4 de
noviembre entretanto la televisión
estatal informó que los rebeldes
escondían armas en una iglesia de adi
min son atacados cuando revisamos el
aeropuerto y el terreno en general
encontramos varias fosas grandes de las
patas de una chico díaz caro en salud no
sólo recientes sino algunas de hace
tiempo esto no es un cementerio la
pregunta es como propiedad pública se
convirtió en un cementerio de sudán la
agencia de naciones unidas para los
refugiados señaló que se necesitan 150
millones de dólares para ayudar a los
miles de etíopes que ha dejado el
conflicto de fortis hay alrededor de 44
mil refugiados que han llegado en las
últimas semanas y aunque el ritmo ha
bajado aún hay cientos de personas
están cruzando la frontera a diario
singh devolver la organización resaltó
que no hay acceso a las comunidades
vulnerables dentro de etiopía que hizo
un llamado al gobierno para que permita
la entrada de ayuda humanitaria
entretanto cada día centenares de
familias cruzan la frontera hacia sudán
generando preocupación por una nueva
crisis humanitaria nuestros
corresponsales a link fallado nos amplía
el conflicto en el norte de etiopía
sigue escalando el gobierno acusa el
frente popular de liberación de tigray y
una fuerza que domina el norte del país
de lanzar un ataque contra una base
militar y ha respondido con la respuesta
a gran escala que podría desestabilizar
a toda la región se calcula que ya hay
unos 30.000 de refugiados etíopes que
han cursado la frontera con sudán
la onu expresado también su preocupación
de que se podrían estar perpetrando en
crímenes de guerra en esta región y ha
anunciado que ha habido muchísimas
masacres
el gobierno acusa también al frente
popular de liberación de tigray de una
masacre de 600 personas a comienzos de
este mes cosa que el frente popular de
liberación de tegra ya está negando
en este momento se han reportado ataques
a sólo 50 km de meckel en la capital de
la región de tigray que es una que una
ciudad de 500 mil habitantes y esto ha
lanzado gran preocupación el gobierno
etíope había pronunciado un ultimátum
diciendo o pidiendo la rendición de las
fuerzas de tigray antes de reaccionar a
gran escala y bombardeando esta ciudad
hay luto en nigeria tras una de las
masacres más mortíferas de los últimos
tiempos en el estado de borno al menos
110 agricultores murieron a manos de un
grupo armado presuntamente islamista las
víctimas fueron enterradas de manera
colectiva en medio del temor y la
tristeza de las familias que claman por
seguridad
boko haram es el principal sospechoso de
haber ejecutado el atentado
nigeria se enfrenta a otra masacre más
de un centenar de civiles fueron
asesinados en un ataque en los arrozales
del estado de borno donde suele actuar
el grupo terrorista boko haram
tras el suceso docenas de personas se
han reunido para enterrar los cuerpos
nos encontramos con tanta gente huyendo
de nuestra aldea sin saber a dónde iban
algunos incluso estaban inconscientes
incendiaron una gran cantidad de arroz
cosechado realmente necesitamos
oraciones sólo dios puede salvarme en su
si bien nadie se ha atribuido el crimen
boko haram ha efectuado matanzas de este
tipo en el pasado y se mantiene muy
activo en la región desde hace una
década por lo que muchas fuentes les
señalan como responsable ocuparán mató a
muchos de los nuestros
decenas de personas fueron masacradas
necesitamos ayuda necesitamos armas y
hombres armados porque tenemos jóvenes
que pueden ser voluntarios para cuidar
de nuestros granjeros mientras trabajan
por favor por favor por el amor de dios'
debido a esta situación de inseguridad y
a las inundaciones los precios de los
alimentos en nigeria han aumentado
drásticamente en el último año en una
lucha por sobrevivir los locales han
pedido a las fuerzas armadas que los
protejan de los atentados
en burkina faso el presidente rock bar
cristian k orégano en primera vuelta a
las elecciones presidenciales con el
57,8 por ciento de los votos y cumplirá
un segundo mandato de cinco años el
segundo puesto lo ocupó edith convocó
con el 15 como 48 por ciento seguido de
ese feeling y abre con el 12,46 por
ciento considerado hasta ahora el líder
de la oposición aquí está el perfil de
caudé
a los 63 años rock mar cristian kaboré
ha ganado su apuesta cumplirá un segundo
mandato como presidente de burkina faso
su prioridad será la seguridad del país
que se ha convertido en un objetivo
regular de los grupos yihadistas que
operan en la región los mismos que
atacaron un hotel y un restaurante en
uagadugú la capital sólo dos semanas
después de su posesión en 2015
rock kaboré conoce bien el mundo
político burkinés pues su padre fue
ministro kaboré estudió economía en la
universidad de dijon en francia poco
después de regresar a burkina faso
trabajó de cerca con el ex presidente
blaise compaoré quien gobernó el país
durante 27 años incluso llegó a ser su
primer ministro durante varios años pero
cuando blaise compaoré intentó cambiar
la constitución para permanecer aún más
tiempo en el poder
rocca bores se unió a la posición en
enero de 2014 convirtiéndose en una de
las figuras más representativas diez
meses después unas protestas de inmensas
proporciones expulsaron a blaise
compaoré del poder y rock mar cristian
kaboré logró que la gente olvidara su
larga trayectoria junto a él
posteriormente ganó las elecciones
presidenciales de 2015
bajo el apodo de presidente diesel
debido a que le gusta tomarse su tiempo
antes de anunciar una decisión que le
pasará a otros cinco años en el palacio
[__] no
hablamos ahora del coi 19 porque cuando
la carrera por la vacuna se acelera la o
ms lanzó una alerta por la situación en
los países africanos la organización
mundial de la salud explica que el
continente no estará listo para afrontar
una vacunación masiva debido a las
dificultades financieras y logísticas en
la región
en momentos en que la comunidad
internacional saluda la eventual llegada
al mercado de prometedoras vacunas las
autoridades sanitarias africanas alertan
que el continente podría sufrir las
desastrosas consecuencias de esta
carrera liderada por los países ricos
sabemos que los países africanos están
inquietos y esperamos que la reserva de
millones de dosis de vacunas por los
países ricos no les suponga una
desventaja para el acceso a los
tratamientos si soplas el continente
todavía no está listo para desplegar una
campaña de vacunación a gran escala los
principales obstáculos el costo y la
logística de las operaciones el acceso a
1,5 millones de dosis estimadas para
vacunar al 60% de la población africana
necesitaría una inversión de más de 55
billones de dólares un coste estimado
que corresponde solamente a la compra de
las vacunas a lo que habría que sumar el
precio del material almacenamiento y
distribución y que podría elevarse
considerablemente si fuera necesaria una
segunda campaña de vacunación
que disponemos de vacunas que son
efectivas o que al menos parecen serlo y
que tenemos la previsión de
distribuirlas de manera masiva no se
debería frenar la investigación y el
desarrollo de nuevas vacunas todavía no
sabemos cuánto tiempo durará la
inmunidad de estas vacunas que están por
llegar amigo la semana pasada el número
de casos de coronavirus confirmados en
áfrica superó los 2 millones y la oms
advirtió que el continente se dirige
hacia una segunda ola de infecciones en
este momento se han efectuado alrededor
de 21 millones de tests en el continente
africano que cuenta con más de 1300
millones de habitantes
en noticias deportivas falleció a los 42
años senegalés papa bouba diop recordado
por su gran papel en el mundial de
corea-japón 2002
en el que su selección alcanzó los
cuartos de final es dios' marcó el único
tanto de la victoria senegal contra
francia en el partido inaugural de esa
copa del mundo y que fue el primer tanto
de ese país en la historia de la
competición global según la federación
senegalesa fútbol dios falleció después
de una larga enfermedad
vamos ahora con temas musicales porque
hablamos con el rapero lucius uib y un
senegalés residente en eeuu que está
presentando al mercado su nueva canción
el sencillo se titula killed my bike y
es un grito de apoyo al movimiento black
light matters
el artista pide el fin de la violencia
policial y del racismo en el mundo
entero desde su residencia en washington
desilusión white y nos junto así que se
inspiró para crear esta nueva canción
buenos días a todos
buenas tardes depende de donde ustedes
estén actualmente en el mundo white y si
mi nombre artístico es y ver qué
significa un joven que cree en sí mismo
yo soy un artista un rapero que comparto
con mi público mi vida cotidiana abrió y
le envío un saludo a toda la gente que
france24 en américa latina con entre el
doble aunque sé que me puse a fairly rap
y empecé a hacer el rap porque quiero
ser la voz de mi pueblo porque amo mi
herencia africana que viene de senegal y
yo trato de mezclar la cultura africana
con la cultura urbana americana y eso es
muy importante para mí
efe
y yo trato de introducir la cultura
africana al público americano y esta es
la razón por la cual hago mi música
american y american y brasil
es mi nueva canción se está haciendo
viral y se llama killed my bike y está
dedicada al movimiento black lights
matters
un tema de actualidad en eeuu que está
impactando a los negros de aquí queremos
tener niños y queremos verlos crecer
pero nada nos asegura que esto será
posible con la policía que nos mata
sistemáticamente por el color de nuestra
piel y lengua a kurt zouma du mont
pues justamente con la buena música de
lucius web y su nueva canción killed my
life finalizamos este capítulo de áfrica
siete días pero antes los invitamos a
continuar con más en nuestra página web
france24 punto conquense con nosotros
nos vemos más adelante
no lo vi
no vivas
ah
[Música]
y